get out your paddles whoo you better
believe that to better and celebrate
jingles day because this episode has
more twists than a [ __ ] roller
coaster yes episode three of American
Horror Story 1984 is jam-packed with
cool kills and new theories so I'm gonna
break down the episode and what it could
mean for the season you'll want to stick
around till the very end for even more
tinfoil hat conspiracies about Montana
Brooke and the Night Stalker so here we
go the episode begins right where we
left off with the Night Stalker trying
to break down the door to the infirmary
we saw him last episode nearing his way
to ray Chet Brooke and Rita who have
gone in search of the car keys so they
can make their escape The Night Stalker
smashes his way through the window which
they quickly board up when Ray has quite
possibly the stupidest suggestion ever
the four of them split up and the
slowest will be the one who gets caught
that's that's stupid but before a plan
can be made the Night Stalker bursts
through the door and Ray gets caught in
his way now here is where I caught
something really weird this is the shot
of Ray right when the Night Stalker
bursts down the door take note of his
jacket we then cut to the Nightstalker
and then back to Ray but look at his
jacket now covered in blood splatter now
this could just be a simple mistake they
made when filming or be if you believe
the theory that they're all actors or
that this is some sort of Groundhog Day
that repeats over and over again it
could be another subtle hint that that's
what we're watching ray gets the crap
sloshed out of them and is saved by Chet
who Rams the Night Stalker into the
window and instead of finishing him off
they just kind of leave him there
meanwhile at the other camp Montana
trevor tried to snap Xavier out of his
shell shock while they believe mr.
jingles is trying to make his way in now
there's something interesting here -
right before jingles leaves there's a
sound of a motorcycle
but we can't be sure if this is from the
two pranksters or someone else the
pranksters hurl a flaming bag of crap
but here's yet another weird editing and
I'm hesitant to say it mistake check out
this shot of the flaming poo taken from
the season to come preview and compare
it to the one that was shown this
episode one is clearly wearing a mask
while the other is not is this just a
mistake and they reshot it or digitally
added in a mask who knows but these
little mistakes are starting to add up
the fun is short-lived as the two
pranksters are viciously murdered by the
real mr. jingles
apparently it's customary for local kids
to play pranks during jingles day the
anniversary of the camp redwood Massacre
jingles cuts off one of the kids ears as
Trevor Montana and Xavier make a run for
it
Brooke and Rita have split from Chet and
Rey when we hear a scream coming from
Chet and rays direction they've fallen
into a pit of spikes and Chet seems to
have gotten the worst of the two now
what's interesting about this is that it
couldn't have been jingles who set up
this trap he just got to camp redwood a
few hours ago so someone else must have
riddled these woods with traps my best
guess is that this was Rita as we'll
later find out she's in cahoots with
jingles now this is another interesting
scene jingle stumbles across one of the
pranksters who we learn was brought in
to the prank because his mother paid the
other kids
he doesn't have glasses uses an inhaler
as reverence for jingles and just wants
to be a badass for the night jingles
lets him live now it could be because
jingles feel sorry for him or sees a bit
of himself in this kid either way it
proves that there's more to jingles than
meets the eye
he doesn't simply kill everything that
gets in his way
Rey tries to get the spike out of Chet's
shoulder but if he does Chet will likely
bleed to death
Chet thinks it was jingles who dug the
pit since it's a punji pit to trap used
by the Vietcong during the Vietnam War
and we know jingles used to fight NAMM
but if Rita is working with jingles it's
possible that she could have learned
about these traps through him Brooke and
Rita are waiting for the others when
Brooke suggests they go and get help
Rita says and leave everyone here to
fend for them
your friends went bail on you like that
uh we know one who would Reta gives her
the keys and in the first big twist of
the season she drugs Brooke before she
can go showing us that she's in league
with jingles which we'll get into in a
bit after all last episode we saw her
confronted by him but we never saw the
actual fight they were likely planning
out the next steps we find out a week
ago that Rita is actually renowned
psychologist Donna chambers so good in
fact she was able to get new information
out of such killers as Ted Bundy and
John Wayne Gacy also interesting to note
that John Carroll Lynch the man who
plays jingles also played Gacy in season
sevens cult
whereas hopple believes some people are
simply pure evil Donna believes
otherwise and is able to convince hopple
of letting her interview him
Donna meets with jingles and is able to
break through to him everyone has said
he's in the irredeemable monster but
Donna believes otherwise external events
such as Vietnam caused him to go crazy
if she can pinpoint what made him snap
and what he did she can maybe prevent
future killings from happening we also
learned that jingles never remembered
killing those kids that's very important
and it was actually the doctors who said
he had this psychotic break
leaving the theory that it was Margaret
who's the real killer still on the table
Rita's talk about trauma being a cause
for serial killing could also correlate
with characters like Brooke and Xavier
who have had traumatic experiences in
the past
Donna proposes an absolutely outrageous
plan she needs to witness jingles in his
natural habitat and helps him break out
but providing him with his bag and knife
but when jingles prod sir as to why'd
she do this she simply says I have my
reasons so don't count out that Donna
has an ulterior motive for this entire
operation and here we have our first
glimpse of the real nurse Rita who we
saw in the preview video Donna is
following her as they drive into Roy's
gas station the same one from episode 1
Rita suggests they convoy up and Donna
says something very peculiar here if you
ask me all those murders
the availability of pornography and the
objectification of women in our culture
this is the second time she's mentioned
how bad pornography is and I can't help
but think how in episode 1 margaret
ranted about how she fought alongside
Charles Keating an anti pornographer who
took on Larry Flynt it makes me wonder
if there is a deeper connection between
margaret and donna and this is exactly
what I'd expect a gas-station washroom
to look like Rita returns to find Donna
missing so she heads on over to Camp
redwood only to find Rita in the back of
her car we flash forward to find that
Rita isn't really a nurse shocker and
that she gave Brooke horse tranquilizers
speaking of people pasta we have Chet
who doesn't seem to be doing too well
ray thinks this is the perfect
opportunity to get something off his
chest so he tells him his traumatic
experience
remember that trauma has been a big part
of this season but how the writers are
gonna wrap it all together thir
matically remains to be seen we learned
that ray left LA because he was in
trouble during a hazing incident for his
fraternity Omega sigh a new recruit chan
falls down the stairs and ray believes
he's dead instead of calling an
ambulance and jeopardizing the future of
the fraternity ray takes one for the
team and throws Chan off a cliff but
Chan isn't dead ray tries to help him
but Chan rips off his watch when Ray
found out Chan's car had been found and
his watch would be inside the car he
knew he had to get out of the city
this incident made ray drop out of
school and get a job at a hospital we
learned in Episode one that Ray used to
be an orderly so it's possible he could
have a connection to jingles as asylum
ray learns that Chet heard his entire
story and decides to leave the guy who
moments ago saved his life this is not a
great look for ray this episode Trevor
Montana and Xavier argue about saving
Margaret and birdy after all
chef birdy is good people hiding in the
boathouse they find Rita remember it was
Donna who drugged her not jingles so we
can deduce that Donna isn't a murderer
she's merely setting up things for
jingles to finish off later which is
exactly what he does
again I could totally be looking too
deep into things but my eyes were drawn
to this locket and I'm wondering if it
were to be opened if there would be a
picture of her and any of the other
characters ray runs into Xavier
River in Montana and lies to them about
how he lost Chet they tell him that Rita
isn't the real Rita and rate argues with
them about going back to save Margaret
and Bertie
Trevor gives him his motorcycle keys and
tells him to go to the call box to call
the police
but now that we know Ray is likely
wanted by the police and earlier this
episode said every man for himself my
guess is that he'd never call the police
anyway
Montana goes with Ray as well and this
also makes sense because earlier she
argued against going back to look for
Margaret and Bertie jingles is alerted
to the sound of Chet but it's a fake out
Xavier and Trevor helped him out and
they learned the truth that ray left
Chet to die
Trevor musters his big dick energy and
throws who he thinks is jingles into the
pit but it's actually our inhaler guy we
met earlier in the episode but what I
think is most interesting is the absence
of this shot which we saw in the season
to come trailer we have jingles pouring
gasoline into the pit with ray now this
could mean a few things a that this is
something we'll see in the future be
it's a total fake out just to throw us
off but usually a show wouldn't go
through the lengths of shooting this
just for a quick 1 second shot in a
trailer or see that we're going to
eventually deal with multiple timelines
that will come back to camp redwood
somehow and the characters will go
through the same night but different
things will happen
ray and Montana make a run for the
parking lot but as soon as they're
confronted by the Night Stalker Ray
takes the motorcycle leaving Montana in
the dust but he finally gets what's
coming to him as mr. jingles decapitates
him but before he dies ray says what I
think is the most important line in the
entire episode quote sucka nut camp
redwood see you in another life now
we've already seen one character have
multiple lives the hitchhiker and we
previously discussed this shot of Ray in
the pit with mr. jingles is it possible
this night repeats over and over like
some sort of Groundhog Day the end of
the episode leaves us with another huge
twist that Montana in the Night Stalker
are lovers ending with Montana asking
why he hasn't quote killed her yet this
her is likely referring to Brooke after
all we already know the Night Stalker in
Brooke have a history but the history
we've seen is from Brookes perspective
what if that perspective is
reliable from this brief interaction it
seems Montana is the one pulling the
strings she's the one with the vendetta
against Brooke what if there's a more
nefarious side to Brooke we haven't seen
one of the more curious shots we saw the
season was in episode 1 where Brooke
briefly shows us her jewelry box not
only are there a few rings here but
later that night when the night stalker
visits her the first thing he asked for
is her jewelry the night stalker came
into her house with the intention of
finding this specific ring at the behest
of Montana which is the same exact ring
we see in the wedding flashback in
episode 2 this likely means there is
some sort of connection between Montana
the ring and Joseph Cavanaugh perhaps
Montana was a jealous ex-lover or a
family member hell-bent on revenge will
need to stay tuned to find out this
episode was nuts and as always I want to
hear your theories in the comments below
make sure to give the video a like and
subscribe with the Belon to get the
latest American Horror Story breakdowns
you can also find me on twitter at
things story whitey until next time
remember daddy loves you very much